health officials are urging americans to
be cautious this thanksgiving as a covet
cases rise nationwide the seven day
average of new infections is more than
92 000 that's up nearly 30 percent over
the past two weeks hospitalization rates
are starting to rise too on friday the
cdc endorsed vaccine boosters for all
adults as authorities warn of a
post-holiday surge of covet infections
president biden's chief medical advisor
dr anthony fauci joins us now to sort it
all out for us dr fauci you know i
always feel glad to see you especially
during this time when we're all trying
to figure out what what in the world is
happening here make it stop because it
seems like just when we make two steps
forward we're taking two steps back the
cases are up the infections are up what
is happening
well as you go into the colder weather
as you go into a season where people
travel where people congregate
and you have a virus that is as
transmissible at delta
you have an issue if you're not
vaccinated and even in a situation where
we have highly effective and safe
vaccines
we still uh gail we still have 60
million people in this country who are
eligible to be vaccinated who have not
been vaccinated which means that the
dynamics of infection as you've shown on
the screen
with a daily average of now
92 000 cases
we've got to be careful that doesn't
mean we can't enjoy the holidays we can
be with our families if you're
vaccinated great
get boosted we now know that boosters
you're eligible to be boosted if you're
18 years or older for the vaccines that
have been available the two mrnas as
well as j and j
go out and get vaccinated children in
fact
five to 11 now 28 million of them are
eligible to be vaccinated you do that dr
yeah
do you think we're now at the point in
order to be fully vaccinated and be
protected you really do have to get your
booster too it's a hard pill for people
to swallow but isn't that the reality of
the situation we're living with today
gail it's a great question we want to
make sure that we get the people
initially vaccinated we want to make
sure they do that because you don't want
to have people be thinking well the
vaccines are not effective right now
fully vaccinated is two doses of the
mrna and one dose of the j what we're
seeing
and we will move on these data gail when
we get it it looks like boosting
individuals
dramatically increases the level of
protection and that's the reason why
you've heard me over and over again yeah
be very bullish about telling people if
you've been vaccinated six months ago or
more
and you have the mrna get a booster and
if you have the j and j two months or
more ago get boosted whether or not
that's going to ultimately be the
optimal it is entirely conceivable that
that's the case
rather than worry about that now and
confuse people
just get boosted if you're vaccinated we
don't want to confuse people about what
is or is not fully vaccinated get
personal
dr falci as we have these conversations
about covet and we keep talking about
boosters and vaccinations um which i am
an advocate for i have a question though
what happened to the conversation that
hurt immunity can help us get back to
normal
yeah well first of all herd immunity is
a concept that when you have a certain
percentage of people and we don't even
know what that number is nate so we got
to be careful of people who are
vaccinated and fully protected and those
who've been infected and then have a
durable immunity that you will get a
situation where the virus has no place
to go but we have a lot of moving parts
here a
we have 60 million people who are
eligible to be vaccinated among adults
who are not being vaccinated you have
waning immunity it's a reality we just
have to face it when you get vaccinated
you get a high degree of protection but
after several months the immunity wanes
even if you are infected and recover
the immunity wanes so when you're
talking about herd immunity there are
multiple different parts
so my recommendation for everyone not to
be confused
is don't be looking for a number which
is going to be hurt immunity just get
vaccinated if you're not vaccinated and
if you are
get boosted clear message no ambiguity
dr that is a clear message i'm hoping we
can have another clear message on my
next question we've got about 30 seconds
left a lot of families trying to
determine whether they should ask their
guests arriving for thanksgiving to get
tested
what do you say to that
i think that's a reasonable idea for
that extra level of protection it isn't
a firm requirement but i think if you
want to go that extra step
particularly when you're in a region
where there's a lot of infection and
people are traveling it is not at all
unreasonable to tell people to get a
test one of those rapid tests 24 hours
or so before you go in in an indoor
setting with people that's a pcr not an
antigen
no antigen tests are the rapid test the
pcr will take a while yeah you can do an
antigen test it isn't the most sensitive
of the test but it can tell you when you
have enough virus in your nasopharynx to
transmit
yeah i had a weird thing this weekend
going to a gathering they took the one
of those rapid tests it first showed
positive and then there were two
negatives after that what should you
believe if that happens to you
you know that's a tough one gail i mean
that's the reason why when you see that
shut down the room yeah well no then you
get a pcr the way tony was just
suggesting okay i mean i mean the pcr is
the much more sensitive but if you want
something rapid right away you're
getting ready to go someplace you need
to know in a half an hour 15 minutes get
a rapid test
all right dr anthony fauci good to see
you happy thanksgiving i know we'll be
talking to you again thank you thank you
very much take care bye bye